there are a lot of hard things you can
deal with in life I'm just giving you
tenable if I don't list something that
you've got or I want to hear about it
tweet me at Patrick with David and by
the way if you have not yet joined the
notification squad on value team and
click on that little alert button on the
bottom here every time videos come out
you want the first to hear about it so
let me get right into it in no specific
order every one of these things are
difficult I'm just sharing it with you
okay first one get married marriage is
not the easiest thing you're doing life
here's why how often have you argued
with yourself how often do you get along
with yourself how often do you find
yourself being annoyed with yourself for
so many different reasons right have you
done that before nothing about it this
way add another person on top of your
own self so you don't get along with
yourself let alone find another person
to get along with and then you have your
financial issues his financial issues or
her financial issues her family his
family cousins relatives gossip times
two and a half and then go out and do
your business to all this other stuff
that you have to do follow I did a video
on this that gets into very specific
details it's called who to marry and how
to marry if you haven't watched it I
highly recommend any body who is single
not married yet to go watch it if you
are married avoid this video at all cost
if you're already married it's just for
the people that are not married yet
harren thing is number two let me tell
you why parenting is also on this list
think about it this way you can work at
a place it doesn't work out you can quit
and go to another place and that's fine
you don't have to put up with that
person ever again you can have a
boyfriend or girlfriend break up even a
husband or a wife you can have a divorce
with and you'll never have to deal with
them ever again there's a lot of people
I've got a divorce haven't seen their ex
for 4050 years but if you have a kid
that's permanent that kid is going to be
part of your life forever if you are
somebody who wants to be known as a good
parent and you want to do your
responsibilities of being a parent your
heart one is here if you have one kid
there's another heart that's walking all
over the place if you have two three you
got three for them all over the place
and you're always thinking about them
you can be in the middle of an office
you're doing whatever you're doing
you're still thinking about you
wondering how they're doing how's their
help you know what they're going through
it they doin okay how they're doing
whatever it is for the rest of your life
parenting doesn't come with a manual you
kind of have to figure out a way how to
parent by itself you can read all these
other books there's just a lot of
surprises that comes on top of that so
it's one of the most difficult things
you'll ever do
number three becoming an entrepreneurs
gotta be one of the hardest things
you'll ever do this is why you have no
idea what it takes to run a business if
you've never ran one before you could
have been I know many great executives
but there were a lousy entrepreneurs I
know many great sales people who were
incredible at selling but they were
lousy entrepreneurs
imagine if you have a personal life and
you got a wife and kids and family and a
husband all this other stuff you're
handling right you got another family
that you're running is well that's
relying on you to make all the right
decisions to stretch the dollar to make
sure you don't make any bad mistakes
that causes the business to go out of
business
half the time you have no clue what to
do because you've never been there
before
number four health you don't ever think
about health unless something bad
happens to you when it comes out too if
you've always been healthy like I
whatever help is something your grandma
tells you take care of your health you
don't need to think about your health
I'm 27 years old I'm always gonna be
healthy five years ago all of a sudden I
catch myself I can't talk I can't even
raise my voice matter of fact go watch
value teaming videos when they used to
be two minutes were Pat and listen to my
voice my voice coming out you don't even
hear it I couldn't even come on and
speak to you so it happened for a week
for two weeks but anything was a big
deal I started drinking honey all this
stuff three weeks four weeks a month two
months three months six months this has
happened and it's getting worse I go to
the doctor he looks at it said this may
be cancerous and he looks at my tonsils
here he said this may be cancerous we
need to do surgery me immediately we do
surgery they cut it out they said we
don't know what it is here but we're
gonna let you know I'm in Columbia when
I get the news and they tell me that
this is not cancerous benign but I
couldn't talk for a month straight
on Thanksgiving Thanksgiving to me was a
week after the surgery and I wasn't able
to speak for one straight months so I
Thanksgiving I'm sitting there
everybody's saying Pat finally we get to
do the talking and you have to listen to
all of us because you can't say nothing
back I had every single relative talking
smack to me on Thanksgiving it was
probably their best Thanksgiving they
ever have well you know what happened to
me here's what happened to me in that
month I told myself wow we don't even
think about it
we get paid to talk I'm at a business of
talking to people selling if I can talk
can I really express my feelings to
another person through text or
communication imagine I'm trying to sell
something here can you read this please
can you read that please wouldn't happen
this is a gift health you're young you
think you're infamous for the rest your
life you're untouchable
believe me it's one
most important things that is why it's
important to take care of it while
you're younger so you don't have to deal
with it while you're in your 70s and
your 80s number five
overcome an addiction now keep this in
mind everybody you know is addicted to
something let me explain to what I mean
by this some people are addicted to TV
some people are addicted to video games
to porn to sports to athletics to ESPN
to sex to business to making money a lot
of different types of addictions and
they're not necessarily gonna hurt you
tremendously but addictions to things
like drugs and alcohol that can really
ruin your life I remember a close friend
of mine and this friend of mine was at a
pond where he couldn't give up vicodin
at all we were at a restaurant and we
are inside and we just came back after I
was trying to introduce some to pastors
that could work on him and he cried two
hours straight in front of spaz from
Pasadena right and we come back were
sitting there at the restaurant all the
way in the back so this friend of mine
goes to his car to get something out of
his car I said I'm gonna follow him I
want to see what this guy's gonna do I
follow him outside and I come to the
side of the car and I'm just looking
around to see what he's doing and I
noticed he took the pill bottle and he
opened it up put five ekiden sin his
mouth he's about to go like this boom I
held this wrist I said what are you
doing he says what do mean what am i
doing I said what are you doing I took
the pill bottle put in my pocket I took
the pills put on my pocket and in that
specific moment I saw a grown man go
through every single possible emotion
you can manipulate somebody else into
giving you something I love you give it
to me I'm gonna kill you how dare you
take this away from me every possible
emotion you can think about somebody
going through to manipulate know to
giving it to him I was watching going
through this whole thing
my friend standing there so we're not
gonna give it to you and we want to do
the process now in this scenario
unfortunately we went we took him to a
rehabilitation center 14 days came out
he was good for a week and all of a
sudden he passed away he it was a bad
story on how it ended but this is the
point I say this to you because two
years prior to that he was already
picking up some other drugs that he was
working with and everything was
graduated I kept tell him avoid this
stuff stay away from this stuff look
this is the point of story with
addiction I've seen many many people be
able to overcome it
many many people overcome it I've seen
many people say I am willing to exchange
this bad habit I have and they go
through a certain system there's many
great organizations that help I shared
this with you for a couple of reasons
number one anticipation if you haven't
touched it don't even think about
getting close to it if you have messed
with it do whatever you can
control your discipline get away from it
if you're in too deep go seek help
immediately because this thing can
completely ruin your life and hurt a lot
of your loved ones and you don't even
know about it
number six is a loss of a loved one
which by the way it is something every
one of us is going to experience at some
point of your life if you keep living
right think about it I'm in the life
insurance business this is what I do for
a living I sit with thousands of
families we sit with and we tell them
about the fact that god forbid something
was to happen to your breadwinner one
there what are you gonna be doing right
and we can't replace this person
emotionally the loss that you're gonna
have but to make sure we can give you
some income or some money for you to be
able to take your time mourning for the
loss of your loved one here's why you
need a half a million dollar policy
that's the business side of it you know
how many times I've heard stories when
somebody comes back and they die and
nobody expected and it happened out of
nowhere and they didn't think anything
was gonna happen because this can happen
to the best of us right
many people have experiences personally
and again this is why the key is
anticipation to know that every one of
these things is possible if you just
kind of look at and say it'll never
happen to our family because we're so
young you got to be prepared for it both
emotionally and financially number seven
leaving people behind and what do I mean
by leaving people behind listen whatever
you want to do in your life you got to
kind of leave your comfort zone the
friends the family the cousins that you
hang out with all the time that know you
for who you are you're saying this is
who I may be today but man I want this
life and for you to do this you got to
leave them behind do you know how many
friends I had that when I was deciding
to go and spread my wings this was the
one line you ready here's a line hey Pat
so have you made your millions yet Pat
thinks he's gonna be a millionaire guys
where's the millions huh I used to see
you drive a Ford Expedition now you come
with a Ford Focus you are definitely
becoming a million it looks like you're
going backwards more than anything I
remember all these stories every one of
them I went from a big Ford Expedition
I'd go to all the parties everybody
would go my car and we go together
I lost everything 49 K in debt and boom
I pull up in a Ford Focus that I can
barely fit in everyone would say this is
the guy that's gonna be a millionaire
you're the guy that's gonna be somebody
we should fall on do business with give
me a flippin break and I was hated by my
friends for five years because after
leave them behind you want to come with
me let's go you don't want to come in no
problem I got to go do what I got to do
you're never gonna pay my bills and I'm
not paying you
I gotta go do my part not to go out
there and do it it is not an easy thing
to do but if you're watching this you're
going through it if you truly are
serious with the effort backed up to it
go out and get exactly what you want
number eight handling success for the
very first time now some people may say
Pat what do you mean this is difficult
one
the moment you start having success all
eyes on you everything is on you about a
small little mistake you made they tweet
about it smaller the thing you say it's
off family frowns upon it here's a few
other things so oh my gosh I like your
nice car I noticed you bought a nice
house we're really going through some
tough times in our family can you give
us $50,000 oh yes mom yes uncle she
would should I do mom well that's your
family how do you not give your uncle
why do you make all this money you make
all this money she can help your family
right it's the right thing to do and so
you listen to your mom your dad they've
never made millions before here's 50 K
here's 20 K here is 80 K here 70 K
here's - $300,000 of debt again straight
back to square one why you don't know
how to handle success for the very first
time so what do you do about it I
anticipate all this stuff and once you
get it learn to say no and learn to say
I don't lend money but I'll give you 50
bucks you want $1000 I want to lend you
$1000 but I'll give you $100 you want
$50,000 I don't have $50,000 but guess
what let me think about it let me think
about it let me think about it you
become a master at saying let me think
about it let me think about let me think
about it followed up by no not at this
time and you move on so people realize
they can't consciously call you about
money number nine Trust it's gotta be
one of the hardest things to do here's
why it's very easy when you're a kid and
you have your first puppy love and you
love her and you don't think anybody's
gonna do anything to your life you ever
seen that movie couples retreat when
they're sitting down with the therapist
and the therapist says you know you're
taking a heart doing nothing to the
heart and a bulb somebody breaks your
heart that's what happens a lot of times
when you're the first time going through
somebody crushing your heart after that
you know who you trust nobody
you don't trust any your next girlfriend
your next boyfriend you think everybody
is going to take advantage of you and
that rebuilding of trust is a difficult
thing this happens in business with
parents with family with mom would
boyfriend with friends this happens with
everybody and by the way probably the
best thing that happens to you somebody
that does something to you that makes
you lose trust why the sooner it happens
the sooner you'll know signs the soon
you'll know what things to take a
different approach with to prepare in
case this does happen
but then eventually you also realize
life is about trust you know there's a
lot of time a little sip where people
were sitting down doing the agreements
arrangements you write it on a piece of
paper you know why you write a piece of
paper and put a contract in place in
business because that person's that had
an experience that they didn't trust
somebody and the other person has is one
they said listen I don't have to go to
do this with you ever again or anybody
it won't just put on contract yeah we're
good to go let's get to work very simple
this is going to happen in business it
is going to happen in life but if you
anticipate it and you have ways to
protect it you're good to go and last
but not least number 10 massive failure
listen I experienced this at the highest
level of business early on because I
went up and I was the one everybody was
talking about and then boom I had a big
fall such a fall that it completely
messed with me to the point where I was
hiding from the world for one month I
don't want to leave the house I don't
want to talk to anybody I don't want to
pick up calls I didn't want anybody seen
my face my facial hair was growing I
wasn't wanting to see anybody I was just
accumulating debt / debt / debt and so
when this happened I had to figure out a
way how to make a comeback matter of
fact I did a video once called how to
make a comeback as an entrepreneur if
you are going through this right now and
you want to find out more specifically
how to get out of it click on the link
below to watch a video that videos
specifically made for you in closing
listen none of this stuff is exciting no
one wakes up in the morning saying I
would like to experience one of these
hard things in 2018 nobody does but in
reality millions of people do on a daily
basis and this is why I used one word
and that is anticipation the key is
anticipation look take every one of
these things we're gonna give you PDF if
you click on a link below there's a PDF
when you print out that PDF you go
through a top ten what I want you to
write then next to every single one of
these hard things that hasn't happened
to you it may be or it has happened to
you but if it does happen to you what
can you do to anticipate and prepare for
it and prevent it what is it that you
can do make a list of it and then make
that your plan of action to make sure
you don't experience these 10 things and
if you do experience it you're prepared
for because entire key again is
anticipation having said that you got
any questions send me a tweet at Patrick
made David regarding today's episode and
if you haven't yet subscribe to this
channel click on the subscribe button
right down here we're getting close to a
million subs we're about to have our
first live value Taemin Conference where
everybody around the world is getting
together I'm getting so many exciting
messages and I cannot wait to meet you
at the next the first live value Taemin
conference take everybody bye-bye
[Music]